I want to dig in further to Donald
Trump's Twitter assertions from
yesterday that he would have won the
popular vote in addition to the
electoral vote had there not been
massive voter fraud including by
undocumented immigrants in the 2016
presidential election the background is
these recounts have have started Jill
Stein raising millions of dollars
Hillary Clinton's chief counsel saying
we are involved in the recounts and
meanwhile Donald Trump goes on Twitter
and claims there was fraud but it was
fraud in Hillary Clinton's favor and I
don't want to spend a huge amount of
time on this because it's ridiculous but
Donald Trump is saying that millions of
undocumented immigrants voted he this
this is one of a dozen or so tweets
about this that Donald Trump put out
saying in addition to winning the
electoral college in a landslide wrong
by the way I won the popular vote if you
deduct the millions of people who voted
illegally also saying that undocumented
immigrants have voted by the millions
number one no evidence for this exists
number two Donald Trump is not citing
any evidence for this number three we
cannot normalize this okay I'm going to
be doing a piece about the right and
wrong ways to fight and challenge
President Donald we cannot allow this
type of thing to be normalized this is
an unprecedented allegation by a
president-elect this is the first time
that he has alleged voter fraud in his
own victory and of course there's no
evidence of the alleged widespread voter
fraud that Trump claims exists is Trump
referencing fake news on conspiracy
websites because there is a disturbing
trend here if Donald Trump as president
is going to be citing conspiracy
websites rather than debunking them
we've got a real problem on our hands
remember President Obama actually ended
up releasing his birth certificate in
order to debunk the claims of conspiracy
websites like Infowars like Worldnet day
I think there's some others jerome corsi
making a lot of his allegations through
worldnetdaily articles and Donald Trump
parroting an info war story which said
that three million votes in the US
presidential election were cast by quote
illegal aliens now Trump's transition
team was asked about this didn't comment
so far and it's stunning that Donald
Trump will not even accept the fully
accept the results of the election that
saw him win but here's the most amazing
thing Trump on the one hand has said
that the entire Jill Stein asking for
recounts thing is a scam if what Donald
Trump says is true if Donald Trump truly
believes that he won the popular vote
which would require at least a two
million votes swing if not more right if
he believes he won it might by a million
that would require more than a three
million votes wing if he really believes
that he should want an audit and a
recount because number one his lack of a
mandate is in great part based on the
fact that two million more people voted
for Hillary Clinton than for him and and
he would be rightly so subject to
significant scrutiny and opposition when
he tries to do crazy stuff as president
Donald and a lot of that would be
because hey you don't have a mandate to
do this stuff more than two million
additional people voted for your
opponent than for you if he really
believes that there was this fraud and
he can actually demonstrate it and say
hey I did win the popular vote that
helps him to achieve his legislative
goals to the extent that they exist and
he knows what the hell they are which is
another issue and he should be pushing
for an audit and a recount it's funny
though that the the people that have
been caught voting illegally or trying
to vote twice during the 2016 election
where Trump supporters the undocumented
immigrants if you believe Trump's
narrative were apparently far more
skilled at voting fraudulently than
Donald Trump's own supporters we're
getting into the holiday season and
Omaha Steaks has some pretty interesting
gifts for gourmet food lovers they
recently sent me one of their great kits
which included some really really great
stuff they also have over
500 gourmet gift ideas they have some of
the highest quality cuts and ingredients
and convenience I don't want to be
standing at the mall fighting to find
that size medium shirt for my cousin I
would much rather go to Omaha Steaks his
website and get really interesting and
unique gifts for people right now there
is an exclusive offer for david pakman
show viewers and listeners you get for
under fifty bucks
to filet mignons to top sirloins for
boneless chicken breasts for burgers 12
ol beef meatballs for potatoes au gratin
for caramel apple tartlets and of course
that Omaha Steaks seasoning and much
more I just can't make this a ten minute
ad and actually tell you everything that
you get as part of this package you can
get it for under fifty bucks by going to
Omaha Steaks com in the search bar type
in my code which is pakman PA que ma N
and add the family gift pack to your
cart and get a seventy seven percent
savings